[Music]
when I called my mother and told her
about this upcoming honor the first
thing she said was well I never thought
I'd have a daughter on the with a star
on the Walk of Fame Jennifer Garner
proving why she's America's Sweetheart
during her speech on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame the 46 year old actress was
honored by friends and former co-stars
Judy Greer Bryan Cranston and Steve
Carell before delivering a heartfelt
speech of her own all of you here let's
I mean all of you you guys you guys too
but okay are the most special people in
the world to me I hope you know that Jen
included a touch of humor a special
shout out to my niece and nephew who are
missing their first days of school to be
here today because in the garner family
Fame matters more than education and so
much love
check out this emotional moment when she
spoke directly to her three kiddos for
my children when you walk over this star
I want you to remember first of all that
I love you you define me not this
wonderful spot in the pavement et caught
up with the peppermint actress after the
ceremony here's what she told us the
occasion meant to her I'm so overwhelmed
by what an enormous
production this ceremony is by it by
having Steve Carell and Bryan Cranston
and Judy Greer here to speak about me
and the thought they put into what they
were going to say how funny and charming
how much I adore them and also for me
I'm team you know I have this whole
group of people here that I've worked
with for decades and friends from
forever so it is it is a very very
special honor
[Music]